so assessing the situation are they
breathing
no rose
they are not breathing and they have no
arms or legs no that's not part of it
where are they you know what if we come
across somebody with no arms or legs do
we bother resuscitating them I mean what
kind of quality of life do we have there
I would want to live with no legs how
about no arms
no arms or legs is basically how you
exist right now Kevin you don't do
anything all right well let's get back
to it because you're losing them
okay too fast everyone we need to pump
at a pace of 100 beats per minute oh
okay that's uh hard to keep track how
many is that per hour How's that gonna
help you I will divide and then count to
it right okay well a good trick is to
pump to the tune of Staying Alive by the
Bee Gees do you know that song yes yes I
do I love that song
first I was afraid I was petrified no
it's uh uh uh uh Staying Alive you were
in the parking lot earlier that's how I
know you
since I was born when it's all right
it's okay you can't live the other way
[Music]
Staying Alive yeah okay you didn't
maintain 100 beats per minute and the
ambulance didn't arrive because nobody
called 9-1-1 so you lost them okay he's
dead anyone know what we do next anybody
Rose I have no idea anyone else we bury
him wrong and check for an organ donor
card if he has one we only have minutes
to harvest he has no wallet I check he
is an organ donor he is yeah give me
some ice in a styrofoam bucket here we
go
all right we search for the organs
where's the heart the brush is hard I'm
not feeling well I need to sit on them
are you okay
oh my God oh my God
can you tell me why you had to cut the
face off the dummy
I didn't think it was very realistic in
the movie and it turns out it's pretty
realistic we had to pay for it cost us
thirty five hundred dollars five
thousand three hundred dollars for a
dummy wow
well okay look
David this is why we have training we
start with the dummy and we learn from
our mistakes and now Dwight knows not to
cut the face off of a real person
please stop staring yes it's Cher
okay that's it nothing for us but this
share thing is out of control we're
going what's the problem you made us
wait for an hour for a table for four
in the back so she wouldn't be gawked at
okay bye-bye
freak
you're the freaks
you know dude it is a little weird that
you're talking to my doll
um I don't think I need a drag queen to
Define normal behavior
[Applause]
but I will say this the look
whatever
[Applause]
work in the attitude
okay you're good
I've had a lot of practice
hey
you're not that great Mr sister
all right
I do a better share than you
you think so
actually it's
you think so oh
[Applause]
are you kidding me with this
okay the hand is perfect but it's more
are you kidding me with this hole
[Applause]
let's get a life
[Applause]
If I Could Turn Back Time
foreign
[Applause]
[Applause]
at least once a year I like to bring in
some of my Kevin's famous chili the
trick is to undercook the onions
everybody is going to get to know each
other in the pot that I'm serious about
this stuff
I'm up the night before pressing garlic
and dicing whole tomatoes
I toast my own ancho chilies
it's a recipe passed down from Malone's
for Generations
probably the thing I do best
ah nuts there's nothing in the mini bar
or as you call it bar
as that morphine kicked in yeah fair
enough always considered you a dear
friend that's a yes
I feel a burning need to share something
intensely personal with you but it's
just so hard to say out loud I for God's
sake don't cry you look like Jeff
sessions watching a black man vote
Aaron this may come as a great shock to
you
but I'm a homosexual
[Laughter]
what's your next bombshell Harvey
Weinstein isn't always a perfect
gentleman
it's kind of blurry
it's better
question what kind of bear is best
it's a ridiculous question false black
bear well that's debatable there are
basically two schools of thought fact
bears eat beets bears
beats Battlestar Galactica bears do not
what is going on what are you doing last
week I was in a drugstore and I saw
these glasses uh four dollars
and it only cost me seven dollars to
recreate the rest of the Ensemble and
that's a grand total of
eleven dollars
you know what imitation is the most
sincere form of flattery so I thank you
identity theft is not a joke Jim
millions of families suffer every year
Michael
oh that's funny Michael
are you Karen
yes honey well Peter Paul and Mary you
are fabulous
foreign
thank you
who are you
I'm Jack Jack
oh Wheels Jack well hello honey we've
talked on the phone a million times I
can't believe we've never met
look at you you little hottie stand up
oh come on
look at you you are a rocket ship out of
here are you a strange person this is
what is this
P.S loving the boobs
perky with all kinds of attitude starbot
right ah God I had no idea you would be
so kitten with a whip
come on let's touch stomachs
[Applause]
[Applause]
so honey what are you doing here why are
you here what's going on what's
happening what's that
well I brought this tassel From Grace
like two months ago and I never returned
it you buy borrowed one tassel for what
to me I have nothing to do today Grace
is taking the day off to move
that what do you think
shoes Chanel fabulous I know honey what
are you telling me will is asking her to
move in with him
into his place that's not acceptable
tell me about it you feisty little Shih
Tzu
[Applause]
no offense
just guessing